welcome to Ruben's select what an
incredible run we've been on since the
creation of our own independent
production company just two years ago
before I do anything else I got to give
a huge thanks to all of you who have
supported us from the beginning as well
as everyone who's joined along the way
we've truly been on this adventure
together and it's been an incredible
ride you've enabled us to build a show
in a production company that I couldn't
be prouder of you've helped us build our
home studio purchase top-of-the-line
equipment hire more great team members
take the show on the road and so much
more thanks to you we've not only
survived YouTube D monetization but I've
also been able to say no to joining
other networks or taking deals that
weren't the right fit keeping our
independence has allowed us to have the
conversations that I believe can help
heal the divide in this country and in
the world but these conversations that
we foster here are only one part of the
solution and now it's time to kick it up
a notch it's time to build real
community around the conversations we're
having here on the Rubin report after
email and chatting with a meeting so
many of you I'm completely convinced
that the next steps in this adventure
are to build a home where you can not
only listen to us but where others can
listen to you as well social media can
be great but it's really not the place
for honest thoughtful dialogue so we're
gonna build something on patreon and
that can get you more involved directly
with us as well as each other all the
while getting away from the outrage
machine think of it as a sane space
instead of a safe space patreon will be
our place to connect with you and most
importantly for you to connect with each
other here you'll be able to share
comments critiques and opinions with
other people who are just as engaged in
these ideas as you are we'll build an
ideologically diverse community of free
thinkers from all around the world all
in one place
that's where Rubin select comes in this
will be our home base for all things
Rubin report powered by the very people
who support the show you this is your
direct link to me myself and my team
will be in the comments and
conversations ready to interact with you
as you interact with each other plus if
you join you'll get some cool perks such
as behind-the-scenes footage bonus clips
live streams chats and much more as we
grow our goal stays the same having
honest unfilled
long-form discussions with people from
every walk of life some of whom I agree
with and some of whom I disagree with
this thing has gone from a little
YouTube channel to something that's
actually moving the dial of the
conversation as our influence grows so
does our ability to really affect change
and I want you to be as much part of
that as I am as our community builds
we'll be able to expand the team produce
more content and introduce you to more
people and ideas which will give you the
tools to fight for what you believe in
level up in the conversation by joining
ruben select now and let's continue this
adventure together
[Music]